jedes Jahr werden Millionen von Euro in
diverse Startups investiert und es gibt
eine Fernsehsendung die genau solche
Investments und Innovationen zeigt aber
eine Frage kommt dabei immer wieder auf
können die Produkte halten was sie
versprechen und lohnt sich ein Kauf
finden wir es gemeinsam heraus und damit
herzlich willkommen zu einem eurer
lieblingsformate dhdl Produkte testen
wir sind wieder da es gibt neue Produkte
und ich bin gespannt was uns in dieser
Folge erwartet natürlich sind die Sachen
wieder aufgereicht von niedrigsten
funding letztes funding ist ein
Firmenwert mit über 1,2 Millionen Euro
da freue ich mich sehr drauf bleibt dran
und seid gespannt ach ja und bevor die
Folge los geht vergessen nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren und dem Video ein Like da
zu lassen wenn es euch gefällt das
unterstützt mich ungemein und ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß mit dem Video
Produkt Nummer eins namens Clipart kann
ich leider nicht auspacken es handelt
sich wieder um Software ist ein
Unternehmen das angibt Mietwagen für
einen Euro verfügbar zu machen und sie
wollten 500.000 Euro für 10% ihrer Firma
was einen Firmenwert von 5 Millionen
Euro machen würde bekommen haben sie
kein Geld deswegen sind sie am Anfang
des Videos und wir schauen uns jetzt an
überhaupt das gerechtfertigt war oder
nicht den Anmeldeprozess habe ich euch
jetzt mal erspart wir befinden uns hier
in der App das ist das erste was wir
sehen und was wir sehen es gibt ziemlich
wenig angebot nur in Hamburg gibt es ein
paar Autos die tatsächlich dann für 1 €
zu mieten sind aber was ist eigentlich
das Konzept dahinter Mietwagen Firmen
haben verschiedene Standorte des wisst
ihr mit Sicherheit Flughafen München
Flughafen Hamburg Innenstadt Köln und so
weiter viele business traveller
verlassen sich auf Mietwagen und wollen
die natürlich dann an den wichtigen
Standorten haben das bedeutet es ist
essentiell für die Mietwagenfirmen dass
die Leute finden die ihr Auto von einem
zum anderen Standort fahren damit sie
dort verfügbar sind wo sie gebraucht
werden und genau hier kommt kein Spiel
sie wollen dass Leute wie du oder ich
genau diese Farben übernehmen und dann
für 1 € in den Mietwagen wir sehen aber
schon in der App es gibt eigentlich zu
wenig Angebote als dass man das wirklich
benutzen könnte um einen Mietwagen für 1
€ zu bekommen wenn man vor hatten mit
den Homies einfach mal am Wochenende
ganz spontan in irgendeine unbekannte
Stadt zu fahren oder in eine ungeplante
Stadt zu fahren dann kann das natürlich
Sinn machen man kann ja auch so Gesuche
einstellen benachrichtigt wird wenn eine
Fahrt von in meinem Falle jetzt Köln aus
möglich ist aber eigentlich gibt es zu
wenig Angebot gerade mit Hinsicht darauf
das ist eine App gibt die nicht nur
deutlich mehr Angebot hat sondern einen
auch noch dafür bezahlt dass man genau
diese Fahrten unternimmt im Prinzip habe
ich eine Plattform gefunden auf der
diese Überführungsfahrten angeboten wird
dicker what the wie krank
dafür kriege ich über 100 € 300 km heißt
die Karre jetzt fazit für mich ist
flipka ein absolutes losing Produkt es
gibt eine App die genau das gleiche mit
dem größeren Marktplatz und mit
Bezahlung macht ich weiß nicht warum man
da zu Flipper greifen sollte Produkt
Nummer 2 nennt sich easy Pen und die
Gründer Tom Becker und Jan Heymann haben
über ein Jahr an diesem Produkt
getüftelt und ich bin gespannt ob sie
sich gelohnt hat den Gründern die 20%
für 25000 € abzukaufen genau das hat der
Dümmel nämlich getan und wir schauen uns
das Produkt jetzt mal genauer an das
Produkt sieht folgendermaßen aus ist
eine Bratpfanne mit überall Käfig Ralf
Dümmel weil in der Sendung hell
aufgeistert und ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich habe da so meine Zweifel das soll
das Schwenken von zu bratenden Dingen in
der Küche einfacher machen das Schwenken
von zu bratenden Dingen in der Küche ist
allerdings schon extrem einfach und ich
habe das Gefühl das Produkt ist wieder
ein
Problemlöser für ein Problem dass es
nicht gibt packaging Kaufpreis übrigens
22,49 man ist also komplett im
Normalbereich im unteren Segment sogar
was von anderen angeht unser Gemüse
kommt mit rein der erste Test
okay es funktioniert zumindest
gut das war jetzt ein bisschen ich habe
es auch nichts drauf angelegt wollte
gerade sagen auch wenn ich mich sehr
dumm anstelle fliegt das Zeug nicht aus
der Pfanne raus man merkt schon dass die
Richtung von diesem Extra gebogenen Ding
passt also wenn man jetzt so Standard
Bewegung hier macht dann muss man sich
quasi nicht darauf konzentrieren also es
wirkt auf mich wie eine funktionierende
Fahne das Produkt funktioniert auch
bleibe aber dabei es ist eine Lösung für
ein Problem dass kein Problem ist und
die frage mich ob das eigentliche Power
Produkt nicht das gewesen wäre dass man
diese diesen Schwenk Aufsatz baut und
der auf jede Fahne passt irgendwie aus
Silikon irgendwie so das funktioniert
dass das extra eine Fahne sein muss weiß
ich nicht was soll ich sagen der Preis
stimmt es funktioniert aber es ist keine
Lösung für ein Problem dass ich jemals
in meinem Leben hatte es ist ein
mittleres bis losing Produkt es tut mir
schrecklich leid und jetzt wird gegessen
Produkt Nummer drei nennt sich Ketchup
und wir kommen den großen Firmenwerten
bzw den großen immer mehr angefragt
waren 100.000 € für 35% bekommen hat der
Gründer 100.000 € für 35% von
so sieht das ganze Produkt aus ziemlich
coole Story der Gründer hat zweimal
Jugend forsch gewonnen 216 und 2017 und
studiert Industrial Design an der
Wuppertaler Universität also kommt vom
Fach und hat sich dieses Produkt
überlegt das ist ermöglichen soll in
jedem Staubsauger ein Zwischenteil
einzubauen das ermöglicht kleinen Teile
aufzusaugen und sie nicht in den
Staubsauger zu verbrachten sondern hier
in diesem kleinen Glaskasten aufzufangen
was super hilfreich sein soll wenn man
sein Ehering verloren hat Kleingeld
verloren hat was auch immer und wir
schauen uns jetzt mal an ob das
tatsächlich hält was es verspricht oh
nein hat er etwa jemand eine SD-Karte
verloren na ja wir werden es suchen
Ketchup wird hier im Prinzip so zwischen
das ganz normale Staubsauger Rohr
gepackt dann schließt man das an saugt
und wir sollten unsere SD-Karte
wiederfinden und damit auch die Daten
das auch der einzige Grund warum dieses
Video hier so spät kommt und ich das
jetzt sechs Monate später sind nämlich
unsere Daten drauf los geht die wilde
Reise
[Musik]
die SD-Karte kommt nicht im Ketchup an
es funktioniert nicht
wegen der saugt ja gar nichts auf
wow das erste Produkt
eins von drei aber auch indem ich es
geforscht habe was man dazu sagen muss
dieses Ding hier die Saugfläche ist
nicht falsch eingestellt die kann man
hier so umstellen so sind die Borsten
draußen und man würde die Dinger nur
noch mehr vor sich herschieben oder so
sind sie eingefahren genauso haben wir
das benutzt quasi in favor von Ketchup
und es hat trotzdem nicht funktioniert
und haben die Sachen nur vor uns her
geschoben all in all eine ziemlich coole
Idee am Staubsauger hat es nicht gelegen
also muss es am Produkt selber
gescheitert sein deswegen für mich ein
losing Produkt und das vielleicht auch
die Erklärung warum das mittlerweile
1,99 € Kaufland im Online Shop kostet
Produkt Nummer 4 freue ich mich sehr
darauf habe ich nämlich die letzten
Folgen immer wieder vergessen mit rein
zu nehmen und liegt seit Monaten hier
nennt sich home shadows angefragt waren
100.000 € für 20% bekommen haben sie
100000 € für 33% von
das ganze macht einen Firmenwert von 300
und 3000 Euro aus und so sieht das
Produkt aus ich habe das sogar schon in
einem der letzten Videos mal ausgepackt
ziemlich einfach und dieses Ding soll
ein Anwesenheit Simulator sein für
Zeiten in denen man selber nicht zu
Hause ist das ganze soll für Einbrechern
schützen und einfach den Leuten von
außen das Gefühl geben dass jemand zu
Hause ist und das Leben im Haus ist für
19,99 € ist dieses Produkt zu erwerben
ziemlich cool ziemlich fairer Preis wenn
man dafür einen Einbrecher davon
abhalten kann bei sich zu Hause
einzubrechen dann lohnt sich das Ganze
auf jeden Fall gerade auch weil es super
energieeffizient ist ob das Ganze aber
funktioniert und hält was verspricht
schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an
um das Produkt aber wirklich perfekt
testen zu können brauchen wir eine
unbewohnte Wohnung in der es Vorhänge
gibt und das habe ich hier bei Max in
der Wohnung gefunden im Prinzip stecken
wir das Gerät ein machen das an und das
soll reichen um Bewegung bzw einen
Bewohner zu imitieren ich bin aber
ziemlich skeptisch und wie wir sehen
sehen wir nicht ich habe jetzt ein paar
Sekunden drauf geguckt und man sieht im
Schatten aber wie ein Bewohner sieht das
in keinem Fall aus also wirklich gar
nicht man muss sich wirklich anstrengen
um irgendwie einen Schatten sich bewegen
zu sehen also es ist was da aber das ist
mit bloßem Auge nicht wirklich zu
erkennen um ehrlich zu sein wirklich
schade die Idee ist wirklich genial aber
die Umsetzung lässt wirklich zu wünschen
übrig das Produkt funktioniert einfach
nicht es ist also ein losing Produkt
Nummer 5 nennt sich early green
angefragt waren 100000 € für 20%
Angebote bekommen haben sie von Nils
Lager auch und Ralf Dümmel der im
Endeffekt auf den Zuschlag bekommen hat
für 100000 € für 25%, was ein Firmenwert
von 400 000 € macht so sieht das Ganze
aus es ist ein Seitan Fleisch Ersatz
Produkt und das ganz Besondere daran im
Gegensatz zu anderen Fleisch
Ersatzprodukten handelt es sich hier um
seitanpulver was nicht gekühlt werden
muss anders als das Standard muss ich
sagen dass wir hier das Packaging
ziemlich gut gefällt wir haben ja
mehrere ich werde das jetzt einfach mal
öffnen um so einen ersten Geruch stest
zu machen
ganz geil eigentlich Mission ist mit
eiskaltem Wasser kühlen ist für 10
Minuten Kühlschrank vorne ist und Braten
ist dann und genau das tun wir jetzt in
der easy-pan die wir gerade eben schon
für euch getestet haben max kannst du
das Fleisch nicht Fleisch mit uns testen
welche authentischer Geruch erfüllt
meine Nase
schon eine echt leckere Gewürzmischung
also ich finde es auch wirklich richtig
gut die Konsistenz ist echt super wenn
man dazu noch bedenkt was ich gerade
eben gesagt habe es muss nicht gekühlt
werden es hat ein unheimlich langes
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum dann ist das
perfekt um sich das zu kaufen im Schrank
stehen zu haben und einfach zu machen
wann immer man Bock darauf hat also es
ist richtig gut mir schmeckt es ist ein
absolutes winning Produkt für mich ähm
aber es ist kein hundertprozentiger
Fleisch Ersatz Produkt Nummer 6 nennt
sich lazy lief und ist vielleicht mein
Favorite Produkt aus dieser Folge bevor
ich es getestet habe angefragt waren
150.000 € für 20 % bekommen haben sie
150.000 € für 20 % von Ralf
was machst du und so sieht das Ganze aus
es ist ein sich selbst Gießener
Blumentopf also der Blumentopf gießt
nicht sich selbst im Blumentopf sondern
die Pflanze die dort drin steht gibt's
in verschiedensten Größen und dadurch
auch verschiedensten Preisen 16,90 €
zahlt man für die 13 cm Variante die wir
jetzt haben und im Prinzip finde ich die
Idee mega geil denn ich vergesse ist
ganz häufig meine Blumen zu gießen habe
aber gerne gut florierende Pflanzen um
mich rum und diese Produkt soll dort
eben Abhilfe schaffen wird hier geöffnet
ist natürlich von mir vollständig
geladen wir machen ihn an und hier wird
das Wasser jetzt eingefüllt
genug Wasser wir stellen den Topf hinein
er hat sogar erkannt dass der Topf
reinkommt sehr krass und klicken jetzt
hier mal die Stufen durch das ja so
wenig Wasser gesehen dass wir jetzt mal
auf Stufe 10 starten jetzt einfach
warten und beobachten ob er über die
nächsten Wochen hinweg den Bonn seid
vernünftig Gießen wird
krass
was soll ich euch sagen ich habe mir
sechs Monate Zeit genommen um diese
Produkt wirklich ausgiebig zu testen und
das liegt mit Sicherheit nicht daran
dass ich sechs Monate brauche um dieses
Video zu Ende zu drehen weil super viel
dazwischen gekommen ist lazy live
funktioniert wir haben über 6 Monate die
Pflanze so stehen lassen immer wieder
aufgefüllt die Pflanze wirft neue
Blätter sieht immer noch nicht perfekt
aus also es ich habe schon Pflanzen
gesehen den ist besser geht aber dieser
Pflanze geht es mit lazy leaf auf jeden
Fall besser als ohne ich bin ziemlich
happy mit dem Produkt passt perfekt zu
mir passt perfekt zu meiner Art mit
Pflanzen umzugehen und kann ich nur
empfehlen für jeden bei dem es ähnlich
aussieht ein absolutes win Produkt und
jetzt kommen wir zum großen Finale
größtes funding größter Firmenwert der
heutigen Folge nennt sich Quinoa
angefragt waren 300.000 € für 20%
bekommen haben sie 300.000 € für 25% von
Carsten Maschmeyer und Ralf der Müll was
einen Firmenwert von 1,2 Millionen Euro
macht was mich tatsächlich etwas wundert
weil ich es von diesem Produkt niemals
erwartet hätte also sorry das ganze
heißt genau auch nicht Quinoa ich habe
verwechselt das eine ist eine Pflanze
das andere ist dieses Produkt so sieht
das Ganze aus Höhle der Löwen Special
Edition Quinoa Power
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel mit Matcha
Grüntee Extrakt und brami Extrakt was
auch immer das sein mag enthält Eisen
koffeinhaltige Pflanzenextrakte Vitamin
B1 B5 und B6 Vitamine immer gut und im
Prinzip soll das quasi den Energy Drinks
dieser Welt den Kampf ansagen die
Gehirne stimulieren einen wach machen
ready machen und das ganze mit komplett
pflanzlichen Mitteln und sich auf alte
chinesische Medizin Berufen auch dieses
Produkt werde ich über die nächsten 7
Tage testen immer wenn ich mich so ein
bisschen dauern fühle wenn die Power
nach unten geht und ganz witzig bevor
wir in den Test gehen es gibt auch noch
eine zweite Variante die sich Passion
nennt auch von Quinoa die das Lust
empfinden steigern soll und die werde
ich ja dann irgendwann mal in einer
weiteren Folge auf einer anderen
Plattform für euch testen kann
ist schon mal ziemlich cool so wie es
sich denn jetzt einfach so
oder runter täglich eine Filmtablette
mit ausreichend Flüssigkeit und der
Couch nicht an meinen eigen
ja ja ich habe mich gerade gefragt oder
die Leute beworben sich gefragt was mit
mir los ist ich bin komplett am
Riesenrad gedreht habe zu rollen übers
Sofa gemacht und so also ja ich habe eh
ADHS aber ich glaube dass diese Dinger
übelst krass
lecker die Leute die mich schon etwas
länger verfolgen wissen dass Martin mein
absolutes go to Getränk ist weil es
Koffein bringt Power bringt gleichzeitig
gut schmeckt und ich bin quasi komplett
weg davon seitdem ich diese Dinger hier
habe also wirklich für mich ein
absolutes winning Produkt auch jetzt
nehme ich wieder eine um genug Power zu
haben weil ich schon am arbeiten bin
wirklich ein Traum Produkt richtig
richtig geil
das war's mal wieder ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn ja dann lasst ein
Video gerne ein Like da vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren und dann küsse
ich euch von oben bis unten denn ihr
seid mit Abstand die besten wir sehen
uns in den nächsten Tagen wieder Küsse
[Musik]